we refer to this system as selective
endogenous encapsulation for cellular
delivery or scent
uh what
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video i'm
going to break down this recent
publication from feng sang's lab called
mammalian retrovirus like protein peg 10
packages its own mrna and can be studio
types for mrna delivery
now that sounds quite complicated so
we're just going gonna jump into it and
talk through it but effectively what
this paper is describing is a
programmable method of rna delivery
between cells which could have
therapeutic applications
so you may or may not know but one of
the major hurdles for rna technologies
for therapeutic usage such as crispr
cas9 is getting the machinery into the
cell and making sure that it's the right
cells that you're getting the machinery
into without causing any inflammatory
response in the body so having safe and
targeted delivery of the machinery
now as i discussed earlier this year
with david liu cheeky plug to my
interview there are currently two main
approaches for delivering crispr
machinery or any rna-based systems into
cells and that is either through the use
of adeno-associated viruses or by lipid
nanoparticles and so there are many
different variations of both of these at
the moment that are thought to have
different tissue tropisms so that means
they can target different tissue types
say for example targeting the liver
and they also have different half-lives
and different bio-distributions around
the body and sort of already gives a
variety of different tools to deliver
the machinery into the cells but are
there any other mechanisms that might be
even more effective or even more
selective that we could exploit
well this is effectively what feng sang
and the rest of his lab we're trying to
investigate in this paper and so i'd
encourage you to read the paper if
you're interested in exactly what it is
they were doing but for the sake of not
over complicating this video too much
i'll try and work backwards and explain
what they created
and the components that make up the
system that they do refer to as send
and so one of the things that needs to
get into the cells 47 gene editing
mechanisms to work is rna rna encoding
the cas9 protein or rna guiding the cast
iron machinery to its targeted gene
sites
and so one thing that's really good at
getting rna into cells is retroviruses
and so retroviruses use rna as their
genetic material and when they infect a
cell it makes a dna copy of its rna
using a so-called retrotransposon bit
tmi but anyway that dna then can get
inserted into the host cell and then
within the host cell that dna can be
transcribed back to rna encoding the
genome of the virus but that rna also
contains the coding sequences
for the protein components that make up
the virus and so it enables it to get
packaged within the cell
leave the cell and then to bind to other
cell types and to spread and then
integrate into neighboring cells dna as
well and so it turns out that more than
eight percent of our genome contains
so-called retro elements that include
retroviruses
and these have integrated into our
genomes for our evolution and so most of
these retro elements have now lost their
original functions but they still
possess some of the coding sequences for
the proteins that enable parts of this
retrofire will transfer to a car and so
one of these ritual elements encodes the
protein known as peg-10
and peg-10 has been shown to bind to its
own rna sequence and form capsids
capsids being the fancy name given to
viral particles and so what they
describe in this paper is how they can
use peg 10 and alter it such that they
could tailor it for different rna and
validates that it can be used as a way
to transfer rna from one cell to another
so this now brings us on to send and the
components that make it up and probably
the easiest way to try and explain it is
with this figure here where you can see
that there are three key components that
make up a tailored send and so the first
thing that's needed is peg 10. and so
this is the protein i've just been
telling you about that forms the final
like capsid particles and also
recognizes rna and so this is referred
to as the cargo rna because it's going
to be carried in the peg-10 capsid and
so because it was known peg-10 binds to
its own rna they took flanking regions
of the peg 10 rna so it was actually
regions of the five prime untranslated
region and the three prime untranslated
region and those segments of rna can be
added to an rna of choice which they
show in this paper works for rna
encoding m cherry a fluorophore
cray a protein and of interest cas9 and
so that makes up your cargo rna it's
your rna of interest with regions of the
peg 10 rna such that the peg 10 protein
combined to the cargo rna and then the
last thing that's needed is a so-called
fusion which is required for cell entry
because pegtin alone isn't sufficient to
get the whole system to work you need to
have this last system that binds on the
outside of the capsid to recognize
targeted cells and so it's a fusion that
also provides an element of selectivity
for targeted cell types and so the three
components together make up send and so
the idea is that it's a modular system
because you can swap out the cargo rna
for a different rna of choice
and so so far as described in this
publication they've used send to deliver
the crispr cast 9 gene editing system to
mouse and human cells to edit targeted
genes and so this is all at the in
featuring stage at the moment just
working with cell types but according to
this mit article sang describes we're
excited to keep pushing this approach
forward the realization that we can use
pectin and most likely other proteins to
engineer a delivery pathway in the human
body to package and deliver new rna and
other potential therapies is a really
powerful concept and so their next
stages of work are going to be focusing
on trying to deliver the cargo to
a variety of different tissues and cell
types and to also test it in animals so
doing it in fivo and so this is very
early stage work but it expands the
toolbox of ways to deliver gene and
editing therapies to cells
and so obviously without having the in
fever data it's hard to know at the
moment if it has any impact on causing
any autoimmune responses or any
inflammatory responses within the body
but it's a neat little bit of technology
so i thought i'd share with you my
understanding of it today
so yeah with that so i hope you've
learned something in this video and
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening